i remember the senior investigating
officer from the metropolitan police new
scotland yard
he got hold of me and he said we reckon
there's probably about
30 victims i went now
i said 500 victims i said that's
probably what it's more like
[Music]
i think when i initially joined the
police service i probably did what a lot
of young people wanted to do was drive
fast cars on blue lights
and then i quickly realized actually
that that whilst that was fun
for a short period of time it wasn't
really where i wanted to be i wanted to
become a detective and i wanted to
investigate
major crime and that is where i went in
two years i was in the divisional
control room
answering the phones assigning units and
that gives you a great opportunity
because what it teaches you
is about managing uh
developing cases stories as they happen
incidents and then quickly after that i
moved into
a vulnerable unit which was looking
after the most vulnerable in society in
our area which was young children
and then moved into uh child protection
and then on to
cid why did you why did you leave the
place
i got to a point where i'd done
everything i wanted to do i dealt with
a very serious crimes child abuse
horrific offenses against children
murders i
worked across the family ladies and
officers for many many murders
and it took its toll i think i'd got to
a position where
i either stayed in the police service
for the rest of my life
my career or i took a challenge and did
something else and i moved on
from being a police officer to being an
investigator which is what i do now
what's the difference between being a
police officer and being an investigator
working in a private capacity well the
massive difference between being a
police officer and being an investigator
is i can't arrest people
but as a police officer of course you
have certain powers
i don't have any powers now my biggest
power i have now is the power of
persuasion in my mouth
and being able to communicate with
people and in fact a lot of the cases i
do now
i have to get to a point where i get
enough evidence i give it back to the
police and then say look please
investigate please take this on to
another level
but there is an advantage of being an
investigator is that
some people do not like talking to the
police
and therefore sometimes people will tell
me things that they wouldn't tell the
police
all these horrible things have taken
their toll with what you said why then
did you decide to keep
investigating in your private life
you know i'm passionate about what i do
i wake up every morning driven
in the job that i do to go and try and
get people answers
try and solve cases but i'm clever about
how i do it as well
you know i use little tricks that
perhaps i couldn't get away with in the
police service
there are things that i do that would be
not criminal but certainly wouldn't be
ethical
i'm always on the right side of the law
but very close to it
we'll often put listening devices into
people's houses
and listen to them to to in order to
hear what's going on
that might be may might even make a
phone call to them sometimes we'll
we'll put a listing device into a house
we'll then put a call into the house
uh generate some kind of discussion so
it may well be that we phone up saying i
want to talk to such and such in
relation to a murder
that will obviously generate a
conversation once we put the phone down
within the house
and then we can listen to what's being
discussed we'll often use
couriers so we'll send couriers to
houses
and couriers will then enable us to get
a forwarding address
because people are often not suspicious
you know amazon parcel turns up to
mr jones at a certain address and the
person opens the door and says oh he's
not here anymore he lives at such and
such
brilliant the other things we do is
sometimes put trackers in
parcels so it may well be that we send a
parcel to an address but we know that
that person's not going to tell them
where they are now
but they will go and see that person
particularly if they're on the run or
want it
so that tracker then goes in the car
with them and then we can see where they
take that parcel
to the individual and then we've got
them that way we do a lot of
surveillance on people so we'll watch
them we'll film them
we'll we'll follow them on foot
following people on foot is always very
interesting
i always say to people if we're doing
surveillance and it's perhaps it's
somebody
that hasn't done much surveillance
before just be normal
they are not suspicious of you it's
amazing what people do
what was the probably the biggest case
yeah so i'm
traveling back from leon and i speak to
my producer i was over there filming and
he said have you ever heard anything
about jimmy savile as being a
predatory pedophile and i went no i said
he's weird
i said he's really weird but i've never
heard that he said well he was
investigated by the police
so i said okay well i'll have a look at
it and see jimmy savile
in his time was probably the most
well-known famous individual as far as
television goes
in the country at the time of his height
there was only two broadcasters there
was itv
and bbc and he was massive
he was untouchable and so the fear that
existed around him
still remained even though he died he
had a legacy about him
and so they were incredibly nervous
particularly nervous about
trying to do something about someone who
dead he wasn't able to defend himself
and i totally understand that anyway i
established that he was investigated by
the police by surrey police which was
actually my force
but it was after i left otherwise i'd
known about it but it was after i left
anyway it gets to a position where bbc
newsnight decided that they were going
to make a program and that's who i've
been filming with because i used to do
reports for them
and they then decided that
they weren't going to do it and quite
simply because
they decided that the police had carried
out their investigation
correctly there wasn't any criticism to
be applied to them that they knew of
and therefore there wasn't a story in it
and i immediately thought what are you
on about
of course the story is not that whether
the police did the investigation or how
they did it
but the jimmy savile is a paedophile
that's the story
so i said can i run with it so i went to
uh itv and i said look i've got this
story and
and of course their response was yeah
how on earth are you going to tell that
and um
and i said listen it needs to be told
and and at this point
he just died and
and i said listen let's i there's
something here there is definitely
something here
and and the exec producer at the time
said what's him up why don't you give it
a run have a look at it
and i very quickly started to realize
that actually
there's a lot of people out there who'd
been talking about him online
so i started to speak to these people
track these people down and they tell me
information and one of the things about
being an investigator
is that talk to everybody
and when you talk to them say is there
anybody else i need to talk to
and then follow up on them and then
before you know it you've started with
three or four people and you've now
suddenly got 14 or 15 people
go to them ask them and and that's what
we did
we started to track down all these
people talk to them
and slowly we started to build up a
picture
that he had sexually abused quite a
number of children
and obviously they were now adults we
went back to itv and said this and itv
again incredibly nervous and i totally
understand why
but as the evidence started to build up
and it got stronger and stronger and
stronger
we said listen this has to be we have to
we have to get this out there we have to
let the public decide
what did it feel like to be
investigating something like that this
this jimmy savile yeah
hung out with the prime minister yeah
yeah
and you're finding out these things and
you're going i know that this man's a
pedophile
and he's still held up as this thing
yeah
i think whilst i started investigating
in the early days
my mum phoned me up and she said mark do
you really think you should be doing
this there was a big story
on the bbc bbc leads covered it
and talked about me doing this program
and there was a phone in and i listened
to the phone in and people were being
really
horrible about me how did they dare i
say something about this man he's died
he can't defend himself i remember i'm
saying mark do you really want to take
this on
and i've had an incendiary device sent
to me somebody sent me
an incendiary device which was sent to
myself
at itv in birmingham which is where all
the post goes
and i remember getting a phone call one
day saying mark
there's an incendiary device that's been
sent to you i think remember things were
right okay what does that mean and
they got the police out there they got
the fire brigade and they'd worked out
that it it was capable of
causing some quite significant damage
we never know who we don't know who sent
that we don't know where they'd come
from
but anybody that knows me knows that i
just
you give me something that's that's
difficult to do you tell me
i can't do something and i'll do it and
i'll do it
and i get a result and i remember being
so determined to do it even when it was
difficult we had real challenge to get
it commissioned itv were amazing
but it was really difficult and i
remember staying
saying to my producer on the tube we
can't let this go we have to get this
out there i remember
at one stage i was thinking do you know
what if i can't get the broadcaster to
go with it
can we finance it can we get a rich
person to finance it so we can get it
out there
it really was we we put our our lives
into it and i
i remember saying to her and to a number
of other people
is if we get this right
then it will make it make a massive
change in difference but if we get it
wrong
and people don't believe us we'll never
work in telly again we'll we'll just be
ostracized from
everything that we do and on the day of
broadcast
it was a defining moment and it was a
defining moment that's been related to
by many um
commentators since is that
it changed really the outlook of
television
of current affairs and it was probably
the biggest
change title change changes occurred by
revealing that this man who was
untouchable
was quite clearly a predatory pedophile
and and the accolades that we received
the following morning from the
press was was phenomenal it then
resulted
in a huge police investigation
i remember the senior investigating
officer from the metropolitan police new
scotland yard
he got hold of me and he said we reckon
there's
probably about 30 victims
oh and no i said 500 victims i said
that's probably what it's more like
i don't think i've been investigating
savile now for a year
and he went gosh he said well okay he
said i i
i can't challenge that mark he said
you've obviously been working on it
let's see
fast forward 12 months over 500 victims
came forward
and it sat on the front pages the
national front pages for 41 consecutive
days it led to the director general of
the bbc resigning
it led to my program and myself being
mentioned in the house of commons
in relation to the impact of the
programme
and it subsequently changed the way the
police
the prosecution service children's
services work in the uk
it gave a voice to so many people and it
not didn't just lead
to maine you know significant other
personality celebrities being arrested
and prosecuted
the likes of rolf harris max clifford
but it also resulted in a tidal wave
effect
up and down the country and indeed
around the world
there were people who came forward
and talked about it and led to the local
builder teacher scout master
up and down the country being arrested
and i firmly believe that it had a
massive impact
moving forward in generating
a view of confidence in victims to talk
that ultimately finally brought down
weinstein and epstein you must be
immensely proud yeah i am you know
people say to me
you know what you did was incredible and
my response to that is
i just did what i do i don't think i did
anything special
i just worked hard to get it the people
that
created the title effect for savile
which
which has knocked on round the world are
those five
brave women who allowed me to tell their
story and if it wasn't for them
i wouldn't be here now telling you about
savile and i genuinely believe that
savile
would never have been exposed
[Music]
every time they arrest you they have to
question you
they have to say something like you you
are not under arrest for this
um you do not have to say anything but
if you
fail to say something that you later
rely on court then this may harm your
defense
because i was charged with 80 different
crimes because they basically made like
each hack a different crime
they were supposed to arrest me 80 times
but they could they only finished
arresting me about 40 times
because they could only keep me in
custody for 24 hours